what's going on guys this is Rob and as
we continue on with our video about
Deadpool kills Deadpool again I would
highly recommend that you check out our
first video where we begin to get into
this series but to make things pretty
short here in terms of a synopsis for
those of you guys that didn't get a
chance to see our first video what had
happened was we had basically picked up
with what appeared to be dart pool or
the version of Deadpool that was part of
the Deadpool kills a Marvel Universe as
he was going through and killing various
members of the Deadpool Corps this
ultimately led him into direct conflict
with Lady Deadpool as well as kid pool
dog pool and dad pulled from the
earth-616 continuity but ultimately this
version of dark pool was killed and it
was revealed to us that it wasn't
actually dark pool proper and instead it
was basically just a henchman and so
from there we found the group had
traveled to the home base of the
Deadpool Corps to find that all the
reserve members of Deadpool were
basically killed off and so they ended
up engaging in a conflict with I guess
evil Deadpool and ultimately Galactus
pool arrived
now with the continuation of our story
here what we find is that again we pick
up with Galacta pool I guess is how you
pronounce it as he's continuing to
basically tell everybody that he's going
to be destroying this version I guess
this earth and consuming it for his own
energy but the other thing that takes
place here is that again all these other
members of the Deadpool Corps the ones
that are surviving as well as the forces
of evil Deadpool are still fighting one
another they're still conflicting with
one another now ultimately as time
progresses we see the conflict basically
boils down to two Panda pool two
Deadpool and - I guess lady'd it will
being the only survivors left and so as
a result alongside The Watcher they're
trying to figure out what to do with
regards to Galacta pool and so as a
result what happens here is Lady
Deadpool takes Deadpool to the I guess -
their weapons cache - where all the
weapons are located at and what she
tells them or tells them is that all
these different weapons have the ability
to kill Deadpool they can negate the
healing factor they can destroy the body
of Deadpool entirely they can I guess
annihilate Deadpool in a multitude of
different ways and so what she says is
that each of these weapons needs to be
taken and Deadpool needs to use them as
effectively as he possibly can and so
what she does is she boards Bea Arthur
ship of the Deadpool Corps and flies it
into Galactus flies it into his head
killing him in the process and so as a
result what we do here is we pick up
with with Panda pool and with Deadpool
from earth-616 alongside The Watcher as
they're basically trying to figure out a
way to get to the location of dark pool
to leave the earth or currently on but
the problem that they have here is that
the Nexus that is used to basically
transition from one reality to another
on this earth has been completely worn
out there's really no way to to allow
them to travel to a new universe and so
what happens here is The Watcher
basically sacrifices himself he
basically kills himself in order to
basically revitalize the entire Nexus
but while this is happening we see that
the Deadpool Corps I guess hand a pool
in Deadpool from earth-616 are joined by
what appears to be a dinosaur Deadpool
and Deadpool the duck I guess to play on
Howard the Duck now they're able to make
quick work of these forces they're able
to actually kill them off pretty readily
and so we find that they actually jump
to the I guess to the world of dart pool
now once they jump to the world of dark
pool again in our last video we had
talked about how dark pool had amassed
an army what we find is that they're
still members of the Deadpool Corps who
are on this planet that don't agree with
the actions of dark pool and Deadpool
comes into contact with them he actually
comes into contact with each of these
individuals and of course they're all
gathered in one location and basically
telling Deadpool from earth-616 that
they're the good guys that they're
basically going to fight on his behalf
in an effort to eliminate the army of
dark pool as well as help him defeat
dark pool proper and so quite literally
what happens is we jump through this
like two-page montage where we see all
these forces fighting we see the forces
of earth-616 Deadpool I guess the new
members of the Deadpool Corps going
against the Deadpool army of dart pool
now is that the full dark pool army it's
just a I guess a good number of them and
ultimately they're successful and pretty
much killing all of them but in the
process panda pool is killed panda pools
hearts ripped out of his chest and so
that's it for him
panda pool is ghulam which kind of sucks
because panda pool was actually pretty
unique and he was probably the most
formidable version of the Deadpool Corps
so for those of you guys who are lovers
of panda pool I'm sorry but we're never
going to see or hear from him again
like
gone forever and so as a result once
this entire conflict ends we find that
Deadpool from earth-616 is the only
member of Deadpool left and so what he
hid what he does is he travels to the
home of dark pool to the dark pools base
of operations and finds the dark pool
has killed off is entire army that he
and Deadpool from earth-616 are the only
versions of Deadpool that are left and
what appears to be the entire Marvel
multiverse and so as a result what they
do is they start engaging in a fight
with one another now what's really
interesting here is dark pool initially
begins to play on Deadpool from
earth-616 he tries to tell him what's
going on in the sense that Deadpool has
basically healed from being stabbed more
so than that he had healed and his
entire outfit was fixed again and what
he was basically saying was that this is
the progenitors this is basically the
writers for Deadpool comics showing that
there's nothing Deadpool can do to
escape his fate and what doc pols trying
to do is get Deadpool to see his ways
he's trying to get him to see why it is
that he's doing what he's doing now
Deadpool initially seems to buy into it
he initially seems to basically buy into
what it is a dark pool saying but then
he basically turns around and says that
at the end of the day while dark pool
may be right the dark pool killed
Deadpool's friends and he doesn't get a
pass and so he chops his head off and
that's the in dark pool like that's
that's it like that's curtains for him
while he chops his head off he shoots
them with a ray gun and that's that like
there's nothing left of dart pool and so
what happens is Deadpool basically goes
about realizing he seems to be the only
version of Deadpool that exists and the
entire Marvel multiverse there's no one
else left but what we learn is that evil
Deadpool had apparently survived the
conflict on on I guess the world the
amusement park world the base of
operations for the Deadpool Corps
initially when khalaqtu said showed up
or I guess khalaqtu pool had showed up
then so what he says is maybe there's
going to be some way for him to wreak
havoc on Deadpool from earth-616 and
make his life a little bit rougher and
that's where the story ends so yeah it
was a very anti climactic ending and I'm
sorry for those of you guys who were
really really psyched about Deadpool
kills Deadpool but when you guys go
through and you guys see various topics
of various discussions when people talk
about the greatest Deadpool stories
there's a reason why this doesn't show
up
number one because it had a very very
kind of climactic ending and the reason
I would go as far as to symbolize is
because the the creators simply just
wanted to basically bring this story to
it and they wanted to go ahead and just
kind of close it all out and say this
concludes the Deadpool Killer G the
trilogy of Deadpool stories involving
the identical former 6-1-6 and the
version that killed the Marvel Universe
so that being said we're going to go
ahead and bring this video to an end
don't like hate me in the comments
because this way the story played out
that's the pic and it will catch you
guys